[Musique]
alors moi je vais vous parler de
l'entrant n'a rien de l'innovation et
des sentiers battus je vais vous poser
la question qui qui sont d'après vous
qui sont d'après vous les gens qui ont
construit notre pays la tunisie sont ils
les conquérants de l'époque de carthage
ceux de l'époque des arabes quand ils
ont envahi notre région où sont-ils les
personnes qui ont réussi à voir
l'indépendance à nous ramener la
dépendance ou enfin sont-ils les
entrepreneurs hommes et femmes des
milliers d'entrepreneurs qui ont osé et
qui ont innové pour moi c'est évident ce
sont les entrepreneurs
ce sont ces personnes qui ont passé leur
vie à combattre et à vouloir réaliser
leurs rêves et à oser j'ai un peu plus
d'un demi siècle
mais d'après google je suis encore très
jeune puisque apparemment on va vivre
jusqu'à 120 150 ans dont j'ai encore de
l'avenir devant moi et pendant mon
expérience donc de par mon travail
on investit on accompagne les petites et
moyennes entreprises des sociétés
familiales en afrique
ça m'a permis quand même de côtoyer des
milliers d'entrepreneurs les
entrepreneurs en afrique mais ailleurs
mais surtout en afrique je vais me
concentrer sur ce sujet ces
entrepreneurs m'ont appris à être un
tout d'abord l'humanise mais aussi à
mieux apprécier les valeurs de
l'entrepreneuriat je vais donc partager
avec vous quelques exemples
quand on voit un peu les entrepreneurs
qu'ils ont réussi ont réussi un peu
partout mais surtout en afrique
on se rend compte qu'il faut pas
beaucoup de moyens pour réussir il faut
oser il faut sortir des sentiers battus
c'est ça les deux messages ces gens là
qui ont passé toute leur vie à faire
face à des à des contraintes des
contraintes qu'elles soient
administratives ou financières
ce qui a fait leur salut c'est leur
volonté d'avancer je vais partager avec
vous lui de l'histoire de trois hommes
trois hommes que j'ai connu que j'ai
côtoyés il ya un peu plus enfin
pratiquement deux décennies maintenant
et qui sont venus nous voir
jeudi nous dont nous trois les les
fondateurs d'afrique une baisse qui est
ma société et qui avait l'idée folle de
vouloir mettre en place une école
d'ingénieurs encore une école
d'ingénieurs alors leur idée était
vraiment de former des ingénieurs
différemment c'est à dire de prendre des
bacheliers da niveaux acceptables et
denfert excédent ingénieur il aura
appris l'ouverture d'esprit mais aussi
un équilibre entre les ardennes et soft
skills ce qui leur a permis aujourd'hui
de sortir des milliers d'ingénieurs
seniors sont employés sans aucun
problème et surtout qu'ils sont formés
selon selon les besoins du marché local
et international
je vais vous parler de mon expérience
personnelle pour mac commencé en 93 94
on était trois personnes on était
ambitieux comme tous les jeunes on avait
un rêve fou donc on a commencé avec une
société avec un capital très modique un
peu moins de 10000 dollars et l'idée
pour nous c'était on avait déjà sept
cette idée folle de vouloir aider les
sociétés familiales a évolué et les
accompagner dans leur développement et
donc de mettre en place un fonds
d'investissement qui pourraient les
accompagner de 100 millions de dollars
mais malheureusement la réalité nous a
très vite rattrapés
toujours et on a dû revoir nos ambitions
à la baisse en effet de 3 on a dû
diviser nos salaires par quatre et la
nouveauté c'est qu'on a décidé d'ouvrir
le capital de notre entre entreprises à
nos employés et partenaires et le seul
but c'était vraiment de recruter les
meilleurs et surtout de les retenir sans
payer des salaires exorbitants ou vue de
l'exiguïté du marché tunisien
on a tout de suite pensé à aller sur
l'afrique et récemment aussi sur
l'europe refaire le même métier
accompagner ces pme pour s'attaquer à
des marchés locaux et des marchés
internationaux et notre première
réaction qu'on en a mis cette boîte
c'était de faire de notre entreprise une
boîte normale normale comme on dit chez
nous en tunisie et que veut dire normal
c'est-à-dire tout sauf une société
unique rend tunisienne qu'on a fait
c'est mettre le paquet pour qu'il y ait
le maximum de diversité diversité en
termes de nationalité en termes de
profil mais aussi en termes de genre et
c'est ce qui fait notre richesse qui a
fait notre richesse aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment cette diversité
on a aujourd'hui une équipe d'une
centaine de personnes à peu près avec
douze nationalités des ivoiriens des
kenyans des nigérians des hollandais des
français des marocains des algériens
bien sûr des tunisiens et même des
bosniaques et des chinois
une autre leçon que j'ai apprise c'est
aussi de pouvoir naviguer entre les lois
et l'innovation
malheureusement pas mal de personnes et
surtout malheureusement je dois le dire
notre pays la tunisie notre chère
tunisie et on le voit tout le temps
surtout depuis la révolution
on attend à ce qu on nous aide à ce
qu'on nous assiste
on est toujours en train de demander des
choses et on connaît pas nos devoirs et
basse
ce que j'ai vu moi de par mon expérience
c'est qu'il faut savoir naviguer il faut
pas attendre que les autorités vous êtes
il faut pas attendre que les lois sont
là pour la simple raison que quand les
lois sont là il est déjà trop tard
ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est passé
avant vous qui a innové et je vais
prendre l'exemple d'un succès story très
connue en afrique c'est le mp ça donc
c'est le mobile payment ou la monnaie -
la monnaie est un mobile comme on le dit
alors cette personne qui s'appelle
michael joseph a une idée d'aller sur un
marché qui est le kenya où il n'ya pas
de régulation et donc il a il a dû
négocier avec les autorités pour pouvoir
ouvrir son produit à tous les kényans
aujourd'hui c'est un produit qui est
utilisé dans tous les services et donc
les secteurs l'agriculture la santé
l'éducation
aujourd'hui plus de 80% des clients
accès à ce service nous même quand on a
commencé dans les années 90 il y avait
pas de loi pour réguler des
investissements on a dû travailler avec
les autorités locales en tunisie mais
aussi en afrique pour mettre en place le
4 qu'il fallait pour pouvoir réaliser
nos investissements et aider encore une
fois ces sociétés familiales et les
petites et moyennes entreprises
alors je n'ai fait que parler de
l'afrique et des africains
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
chère audience combien dans cette salle
vous êtes des maghrébins les marins à
l'est
et on n'a pas tous non j'espère
convaincant alors parmi ces maghrébins
combien de personnes ont déjà été en
afrique
qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut que tout
le monde tous les maghrébins élèves
format nous sommes l'afrique nous sommes
en afrique
n'oubliez pas que la tunisie a donné son
nom à l'afrique
c'est grâce à ces sociétés qui ont
innové qui ont osé qui ont osé aussi ne
pas regarder uniquement vers le nord ou
vers l'est ou l'ouest mais regardez vers
le sud
ces sociétés qui se sont développées
avec les moyens à bord sont rien de plus
et qui ont réussi à naviguer entre ces
lois
ces sociétés là doivent aller vers le
sud vers notre continent l'afrique alors
ce que je le message que je voudrais
vous faire passer ces alesi osé il faut
entreprendre et il faut suivre le chemin
qui mène vers le sud terre notre cher
continent qui est et vous le savez tous
si vous le savez pas je vous l'apprends
le nouveau monde du 21e siècle
je vous remercie
[Musique]